I lied this is in the past case but when
I took last week after Gina fire debate
whether my law students there I won't
know this when I just screamed really
old oh no oh my god
you can't have law students at a witness
interview it breaks the attorney-client
privilege
that's just screaming malpractice hey
legal eagles D James Stone here teaching
you how to think like a lawyer today we
are covering the highly requested how to
get away with murder episode 1
apparently you guys want to get away
with a whole bunch of homicides well
I'll do what I can to help now be sure
to LIKE and subscribe to make sure you
never miss out on a future lawyer reacts
and of course be sure to comment in the
form of an objection if you object I
will be sure to sustain or overrule your
objection
and of course stick around until the end
when I give how to get away with murder
a grade for legal realism so without
further ado let's dig into how to get
away with murder episode 1
[Music]
all right so clearly the first day of
class law school all right so what we're
seeing here is a very large first-year
classroom in law school generally the
classrooms aren't this big in law school
even your first year classes tend to be
less than 50 people often they're 30
people or so mainly because first year
classes are almost always graded as an
issue spotting essay exam so you would
rarely see a class that was this big
especially in a first year class four
times this morning where yes she's a
ballbuster sure but I spent my summer
interning for Chief Justice Roberts what
has the upper-hand in the academic world
but it is clearly the better
compensatory okay so there is some truth
to the fact that in law school you're
going to run up against what are called
Gunners Gunners are those people that
just seem to have every answer to every
question and they're gonna raise their
hand at every single opportunity and
they think that they have a really
impressive resume and you're gonna get
people that are Tooting their own horn
now the kind of things that these
potential students are talking about is
kind of ridiculous you would never ever
ever have someone who is just starting
law school and yet they were interning
for the Chief Justice of the United
States Supreme Court it's impossible
literally impossible and either he is a
huge huge liar or the show just hasn't
done its research now clerking for the
Supreme Court is something that actually
happens but you have to graduate from
law school before you can ever do that
you would never be able to intern for
the Supreme Court let alone the Chief
Justice of the Supreme Court before you
have gotten to law school it's totally
ridiculous
unlike many of my colleagues I will not
be teaching you how to study the law or
theorize about it but rather how to
practice it in a courtroom okay
in general I kind of like that idea
about instead of focusing on the theory
of law focusing on the on-the-ground
tactics that you would use as an
attorney but these students are first
year first semester law students they
don't know anything about the law
so generally that's why law professors
will ease into the curriculum by talking
about the theories and the policy
arguments that undergird our entire
legal system you got to give them a
little background first before you dig
into the nuts and bolts of actually
practicing because those are two very
different things now to our first case
study the aspirin assassin tell us the
facts all right this appears to be an
actual case that that may be ongoing law
school does actually use the case method
when you're talking about cases in law
school what you're really talking about
our appellate opinions in other words
the losing party in the court below the
trial court didn't like the way that
they lost and so they appealed that
decision to the higher court to review
the aspects of the law that were applied
you're not talking about relitigated the
entire case the facts are given to you
when you get to an appellate court the
evidence is set and really you're just
applying the facts as given to the law
or the theory of the law in the
appellate court so it would be very
weird to start out law school without
any of the precedent whatsoever without
really knowing what the law is and
diving into the facts of the case so far
right now what's happening is very
unrealistic and it's not really doing
these students any favors they want in
you unprepared no well yes but I didn't
know there was anything to prepare I
emailed the assignment to the entire
class two days ago oh I didn't get that
I don't know why this is always a trope
in law school movies and TV shows yes
there is substantive information that is
discussed on
day one of class but professors know
that a lot of students aren't gonna know
that and some are gonna be unprepared so
they will help the student out on day
one of class if not on further days let
me help you out
actus Reyes means guilty act at the
poisoning of mr. Kaufman with an aspirin
whereas mens rea means guilty mind more
or less mens rea uh so the answer that
she's looking for here is what is the
mens rea uh required to be guilty of the
crime of murder I guess attempted murder
because the guy was resuscitated well
the answer depends on what jurisdiction
you're in every state has a different
mental requirement for what will make
you guilty of a given crime if we're
talking about first-year law students
we're probably talking about the model
Penal Code which is adopted in many
states but not all the model Penal Code
has several mental states that will
allow you to be guilty of the crime of
murder or attempted homicide one is
being intentional another is knowing and
a third is reckless and it depends on
which particular brand of homicide
you're talking about if you're talking
about intentional or knowing conduct
what you mean is that you either
intended the actual outcome in other
words the death of the individual or -
you acted in a way knowing that that
outcome was likely to occur those are
the kind of mental states that will make
you guilty in other words have the mens
rea of the crime of homicide or an
attempted homicide so that's what she's
looking for think mr. Gibbins it's
nothing more than common sense to kill
well the individual just spoke please
stand and repeat the answer yeah but
this is the first day of class and this
is the stuff that you are supposed to be
teaching them and by the way this stuff
almost never comes up in actual practice
because it's all part of the theory the
philosophical underpinnings of criminal
law it is not the kind of stuff that
you're gonna be dealing with on an
everyday basis you would never talk to
the jury about actus Reyes or the men's
raya of a crime you would give them jury
instructions that lay out in great
detail what those things mean in lay
words not in the highfalutin language of
lawyers this is this is not talking
about criminal law from the perspective
of a practicing lawyer Walsh I noticed
that the verdict wasn't listed here so I
guess my question is did she do it why
don't you ask her yourself this is so
ridiculous this professor hasn't taught
them anything and she was going to move
on after she explained anything about
the case except for the facts for any
given case to have any kind of
educational value you need to know what
the dispositive facts are but you also
need to know what the outcome of that
case is was the person guilty of murder
or were they not and on top of that
where did they get this information in
law school you use case books you don't
use just random pieces of paper that
contain a story about what this case was
so far this professor has not only
taught them nothing but really wasted
their time for 15 minutes if not more I
lied this is in the past case but when I
took last week after Gina fire debate
other law students there
I won't know when I just screamed really
Oh Oh No oh my god
you can't have law students at a witness
interview it breaks the attorney-client
privilege that's just screaming
malpractice you may have heard that
attorneys and clients have what's called
the attorney-client privilege which
means that what you say to your attorney
is privileged and can't be disclosed to
another third party despite them wanting
to know that information but the way you
break that privilege is you have that
conversation in a place where you have
no expectation of privacy or there is a
third party there which breaks the
privilege and guess what her entire law
class are not members of her firm and
they are not the attorneys for this
individual so by having literally
hundreds of people present for when this
person is talking that breaks the
privilege and anything that she is
saying right now can be used against her
it's discoverable and it may be
admissible in court so this is
malpractice to have hundreds of people
witnessing what this poor defendant is
saying this is this is awful this is
this is sanctionable and and she should
be disbarred immediately crazy each of
you have one minute to present the best
defense for this case see if you can
beat my current plan what mr. Gibbins
yes you'll go last in an enviable
position seeing that no two students
will be allowed to present the same idea
use the resources in this office Gina's
discovery file my library the people who
know me even better than myself my
associate okay that's crazy for a number
of different reasons number one if
you're going to trial in two days then
you better have your theory of the case
locked down and I don't know why you're
doing fact discovery you know two days
before the trial goes on you need to
have your facts in a row let alone your
entire defense theory that needs to be
ready to go now on top of that I know it
sounds cute to have a bunch of law
students give their theory of their best
defense but again all of that
information is discoverable the
prosecutor can get the information
that these students have provided
because they're not bound by
attorney-client privilege or the work
product privilege they're not attorneys
they're not members of the firm and it's
I don't I don't even know what to say
this is so insane and such malpractice
that I need a break I need a break
this is crazy
all right we're back I'm not gonna let
this stupid TV show break me
despite the stupid legal things that are
going on we're gonna plow through it
we're gonna keep going
step one discredit the witnesses
step two introduce a new suspect that
person is mr. Kaufman's jealous business
partner Lionel Bryant step three we bury
the evidence there's a very good reason
you won't find any of the information
that she's talking about in any
first-year class in the entire country
it's because she's really doing a
disservice to these students they're not
learning anything about criminal law
they're not learning about what
constitutes a crime they're not learning
about the philosophy of the American
legal system they're she's just getting
into child tactics which there's a time
for that but it's not when you're a
first-year law student why are you here
it can wait Frank you didn't lock up
again speak like I came across this case
Commonwealth V McGinnis which says we
can move for a faster verdict if we
think the prosecution's evidence is
insufficient you're suggesting is called
a directed verdict that we asked for it
and get denied all the public will hear
is there's enough evidence to convict
but you discredited the first assistant
today an ID I'm telling it's a bad one
yeah that is a bad idea first of all
it's silly that he learned about a
directed verdict
from a case directed verdict is a real
thing and it does allow you to get a
case dismissed very early on in the case
however that's a product of statute so
basically every jurisdiction has a
statute that says you can that's a
certain time move for a directed verdict
he would know that if this teacher had
taught him anything in class but
obviously she hasn't but the time for a
directed verdict is at the close of the
prosecution's case they can't just call
one witness and have a good
cross-examination of the prosecution's
witness and say oh well therefore
because this witness didn't do a good
job that we have to throw out the
prosecution's entire case
that's really silly instead you would
wait for the prosecution to make their
entire case call all their witnesses
submit all their evidence and then you
would make a motion to the judge and say
taking the prosecution's case at face
value they haven't met their burden and
established guilt beyond a reasonable
doubt that is a motion you could make
but it's only after everything has come
in not just one particular witness so I
don't know why this guy thinks he's
found the secret to this case it's a bad
idea but it's a product of the fact that
he hasn't learned anything from this law
professor who's the one who's supposed
to be teaching it's bad
how'd you get this wasn't exactly legal
it's the point and we just have to get
creative
Bonnie mr. Bryant you and your business
partner mr. Kaufman had a meeting in his
office on the morning of the accident
correct yes to discuss moving Gina to
accounting so to avoid any possible
sexual harassment lawsuit that's correct
will you please read this email that you
wrote to mr. Kaufman do your Arthur okay
you can't just go up to a witness and
ask them to read an email that they
wrote you have to establish the proper
foundation and this probably isn't
interesting to anyone except fellow
lawyers but getting documents into
evidence is probably one of the things
that takes up most of our time in trial
and all of those are considered
documents that are usually considered
hearsay so in order to get those
documents into evidence
you have to number one lay the
foundation and number to establish a
hearsay exception or a reason why it's
not hearsay in order to get that into
evidence above the objection of what the
other side is going to do now the thing
that we use most of the time is what's
called the business records exception
which is a hearsay exception in most
jurisdictions and it allows you to
establish that record kept in the
regular course of business is verifiable
enough that it should come into evidence
but there are a lot of different
elements that you have to establish in
order to get that information into trial
they haven't done any of that so you
can't just go up especially when the
email is attained illegally they're
gonna have some big problems in
establishing that that email is what it
purports to be and should come into
evidence this email was not part of the
discovery file this is true I thought it
was although my associate is more
familiar with the paperwork on this case
Bonnie oh my god I found the email on
the files given to us by our clients
previous attorney Your Honor I just
assumed it was part of the discovery
fact it wasn't which means it was
obviously obtained illegally enough did
you write this email mr. Bryant
yes and I have to side with the defense
here the emails admissible Your Honor
I've made my decision mr. Williams now
there's a bigger problem in that the
state hasn't turned over exculpatory
evidence to the defense and under
Supreme Court precedent under the brady
case that is a constitutional violation
to not give exculpatory evidence to the
defense the prosecution if they have
certain evidence that is exculpatory
towards the defendant they have a duty
to turn that over to the defendants but
they haven't done so might be grounds
for a mistrial where it might be grounds
for reversal if there was a conviction
they may have overplayed their hand by
using this in court instead of using it
on appeal to overturn the conviction if
that was where it was going to go as
stated in the email you were angry at
mr. Kaufman for taking part in a sexual
relationship with an employee I was
frustrated yes so frustrated that
perhaps you swapped his blood-pressure
pill for an aspirin in order to gain
sole ownership of the company objection
drawn no further questions I hate it
when lawyers on TV ask a question and
then immediately withdraw it what that
means is that none of that information
can come in and you can you can make
good points and you can hammer that
point home without asking an
argumentative question that's just going
to be stricken immediately it would be
better to get the underlying evidence
out and have that remain as part of the
courts record than it would be to ask a
stupid question and then have it
withdrawn immediately I hate it when
lawyers do that the night before the
murder attempt miss Sadowski fought
what does he say on that label detective
Gill cell luxacore it's a brand of
aspirin you had one job
the letters know what bodies we need to
bury text calls anything we needed to
destroy and you didn't so guess what
guess what you go to jail and I'm the
shoddy lawyer who put you there
I mean it is important for clients to
tell you all the bad information so you
can plan around that but I think the
number of clients I've had that have
told me a hundred percent of every story
is probably close to zero and I suspect
most other attorneys have to deal with
clients that aren't always gonna tell
them everything about every single case
that's just part of the nature of the
job so her reaction as if she's never
had a client who didn't tell her about a
single fact before this is just silly
and besides her last attorney was fired
so what's to say that she's not gonna
fire Viola Davis --is firm from this I
mean you don't talk to a client that way
even when they've done something that's
not particularly good for them detective
in your 12 years working for the city of
Philadelphia have you ever known them to
alter video footage to help the
prosecution get a conviction digitally
altering aspirin labels for example I'm
simply asking detective Lahey about his
personal experience within its
department this is the last question all
alone look it's very clear whether this
information is relevant or not or
whether it is admissible or not so -
well for the judge to allow one more
question is ridiculous I would think
that this line of questioning as to
whether some unnamed police officer has
doctored evidence in a different case is
highly prejudicial and is really
minimally relevant to this case at hand
she can ask about the particular tape
all day long but for her to ask about
speculation about what may or may not
have happened in other cases is exactly
the kind of prejudicial evidence that
shouldn't be coming in and the judge
should not have allowed this evidence
ridiculous miss Sadowski is and always
has
and I'm so happy the jury agreed
now it's time to find out who will be
joining us in our firm first the
standout in the class all right
firms don't make hiring decisions based
on a few weeks of the first semester of
law school in reality what happens is
you go through your entire first year
you then get a summer job in between
your 1l year and your 2l year then when
you come back to your 2l year you will
interview with a bunch of firms to
hopefully get a summer associate job in
yours 2l summer I mean these students
haven't had a chance to study let alone
take a final exam and nobody knows
whether they're capable of being in a
law firm or not this is totally crazy
this is halfway through their first
semester in law school this is
ridiculous ah so that Detective is my
boyfriend yes I don't want the job not
if you pick me because of that that you
got him to lie on the stand is that why
I picked you because I thought I picked
you because your self-defense argument
showed you think well on your feet but
we won because I did my job
you think carefully everything after
this moment will not only determine your
career of life you can spend it in a
corporate office drafting contracts and
hitting on chubby paralegals before
finally putting a gun in your mouth well
you can join my firm and become someone
you actually like oh my god this law
firm would not be the only law firm that
is interested in the students of this
law school it's ridiculous to think that
these students are gonna make anything
of themselves unless they work for the
law firm where this law professor
happens to be a partner this is so
stupid so stupid yeah so decide do you
want the job or not no run away run away
alright that was the first episode of
how to get away with murder all rise
oh man that was rough that was really
rough I mean between Law School scenes
that were kind of like Legally Blonde
but much
much worse and courtroom scenes that
were like Perry Mason but even more
unrealistic that was a hard one to get
through as an actual practicing attorney
so all in all I give how to get away
with murder episode 1
a d-plus at best you would have flunked
my class in law school so if you enjoyed
this episode hopefully more than I did
check out this playlist I put together
to includes all my prior reactions
including to suits and The Good Wife so
click on this playlist and I'll see you
in court